I never pulled any punches
what you see is what you get mad man
Kobe had beef when you don't know a
person you have to go to what you hear
what you see you know you don't know me
I got a problem with a guy to take shots
they come to me and they ask me about
whose team is is this than other player
I mean he just frustrated though the way
the world is on this young man he just
can't seem to get a break now this
situation was Shaquille O'Neal and the
perception by the media and the people
or a surrounding Shaq I have another
issue that I'm dealing with right now
this that's real I mean I was the first
time playing basketball where it just
wasn't fun
was a fun I don't wanna play
on things that go like there was close
to go and I think and not gonna go like
that I want to be trading what had been
moving for weeks became a reality Shack
traded to the heat Coby Rios with the
Lakers when was the last time you talked
to Toby I don't know don't care
certain things now when the tough gets
going the true colors come out Shaq
taking potshots at you from across the
country Phil Jackson writing a book and
attacking it was a former player that
didn't hurt you know of course what you
want to do with it
allow this thing to fester within you
better eat you up or are you gonna take
that and use that energy to channel it
when I face adversity and I look at it
as a challenge or an opportunity where
did that come from
what was the genesis for me
jackin us refer to Kobe by name both
players are looking at this as a I want
to excel
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
I knew that it wasn't gonna go in this
is falling apart really quickly for the
Lakers we just can't seem to get out
there in the public eye and do anything
right
the Phoenix Suns they've come back from
a 3-1 deficit that beat the Lakers in
the first round for a Laker team that
went 42 and 40 was eliminated by Phoenix
in the first round for the second
consecutive year he promised a
championship when he came to Miami
first championship in franchise history
it's ironic to lose one win today
[Music]
it has just been a topic since the
season ended as what are the Lakers
gonna do are you saying right here on
this show that you want to be traded
yeah well I would like to trade you and
I've been up late your fan forever had
nothing to do with the name when a
jury's gonna fact but it's the name on
the front
I really mattered then my heart I I just
wanted to be elated yeah I move in a
different direction at this point on
I'll go play on like no way in the world
organization could explain trading away
Kobe Bryant and Shaquille O'Neal sit on
Kobe Bryant and force him to continue to
wear Laker jersey you do not trade the
best player in the world Who am I to not
be able to forgive an individual who am
I to pass judgment or somebody Kobe
Bryant's going nowhere that's dumb
he's got broad shoulders I'll tell you
what I wouldn't be able to handle it you
hear the chants you know who it's for
most valuable player in the NBA this
year Kobe Bryant
we still got many more years to go
we won't play until June I love you not
as did this party started
[Applause]
it was a recipe for disaster way back
before the seasons with Kobe Bryant and
the trade demands but it's turned into
an MVP season form and maybe
a port living for the hostage second
the Boston Celtics are heavier
there's just what is so bad that's all
just want it really bad so you know it's
just uh you just put everything you have
into the game and then you know your
motions kind of flow out of you sweet
hope you couldn't do without one gonna
be playing around y'all not gonna take
that settle for that
that's not about the game he's got
coffee on the way and call me
tomorrow in court I don't care who's
hurt this season we are winning his damn
championship you care what happens
that was metallic
to any other player
Madison Square Garden with 61 we already
had the motivation to do we do can't go
another level or borrow your honor pack
day by day one day at a time as a matter
of fact is magnified sprained ankle
the two best players in the game right
now last years MVP and scoring champion
Kobe LeBron is he as good as Michael
Jordan it's been blasphemy to say it
really about anybody it's an actual
discussion you can happen well I said it
a year and a half ago no way in the
world would I ever put anybody into
conversation with Michael Jordan but
Kobe Bryant is there he's as good as
Michael Jordan on any given day I'm
hungry now more than ever because when
you've tasted it before you want a happy
more desk or to get it done for a coffee
fan much tougher time oh they're too
young
oh they're not tough enough you know
there's a lot of things that we got to
prove is it the best rivalry just dance
Kobe Bryant the Box in LA and that needs
to be said more than that
[Music]
[Applause]
Celtics Lakers rarely disappoint husband
plate seems lost in the finals we'll go
back one the next year Kobe Bryant is he
a season ago in six games he was denied
a title by the Boston Celtics it's this
his time one of the greatest players to
play the game what will the new to you
to win a championship with this group of
guys and everything pretty mean
everything because nobody thought we'd
be able to get back their best clutch
sure on today's game I would have to go
with Kobe jelly beans oh he's the best
play again it's just that simple there's
nothing that Kobe Bryant can't do
today
this guy is highly motivated and that's
on top of the motivation he already have
[Applause]
but here I am get stuck with this
argument you only want the custom chef I
don't want this conversation which is
not fair but yet this is the harding
that people will make and I'm not okay
[Music]
wait today the quarry ride
incredible on the offensive end
just better objects to do
shot a big a beautiful book going with
but series of
good start will be Ryan Reynolds
you feel they do and probably well would
be able to mend your relationship I
don't I don't know I don't care
the only one custom check I don't want
this conversation and I'm not okay
falling down as the buzzer sounds it's
official the Lakers are in fear
once again
title the MVP of the 2000
NBA Finals
Kobe Bryant
did it bother you legal shake and he won
it without shoes I don't know it was
annoying
he's the challenge I'm just gonna have
to accept from the standpoint of
responding to the challenge
of people saying I couldn't do it
without them that feels good
because you prove people wrong